Hellenic army Osaka Sao Paulo might
delete trousers two dozen Newcombe
apartment number no Riyadh circus always
a brothel
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Nicolas booth reason TV and today
we're talking with Evgenia vanevski
director of the documentary winter on
fire which details the 2014 Ukrainian
revolution that ousted President Viktor
Yanukovych the film recently won the
People's Choice documentary award at the
Toronto International Film Festival and
will be debuting on Netflix on October
9th thanks for being here thank you for
having what was going on in November of
2013 that sparked the demonstrations at
the center of the film it started
because the government decided to stop
their negotiations and stopped the
signature of the European Union
association agreement and then the
people decided to come out and voice
their disagreement with the government
and again it started with the normally
simple protests of the people kills
people young people came out to the
streets and decided to voice themselves
in the film you share student protesters
congregating in and almost it's like a
fest of all of us the festival
atmosphere why did it escalate the way
that it did them because it was this
kind of it seemed like a spontaneous
flowering of positive emotion this is
not question to me
I was just capturing history there
because what happened people came people
were celebrating in the same time trying
to key get the attention from entire
world and all of the sudden
spontaneously its escalated for example
you nobody was expecting to have kids
beaten four o'clock in the morning
nobody was expecting people being
kidnapped or than killed so it was
unfolding so spontaneously and so fast
so it's not was even timing to digest
and what's happening it was just
unfolding and me as a filmmaker is my
huge fascinating group they're just
trying to capture every moment and
document yeah when did you arrive and
when you went there what what kind of
film did you expect that you would be
making after the friend called and said
come down because the history happening
here so just come down and let's try to
notice the history document the history
and by the time I arrived it still was
the festival so it was hard to even
predict what was happening I came
actually for two weeks and I wanted to
see all this amazing but different
festival of young people compared to the
2004 that was totally different Orange
Revolution that happened in 2004 all
over the sudden it's unfolded in
different way and all of the sudden I
was in the middle of all these we can
say uprising events movement see and I
was capturing the history a few early
reviews of the film had been critical of
the singular viewpoint focusing purely
on the struggles of the protesters and
those fighting for closer ties with the
European Union would you like to respond
to that kind of criticism do you see
that as a flaw no I intentionally did it
to one side story because the other side
of the story it's politicians and the
police police not allowed to talk to the
camera so as much as we try to get any
answers they're not very allowed to talk
to the cameras and the politicians every
time you point in camera to the
politician his story is promoting
himself and promoting his party and his
agenda it's not a human story that I was
trying to bring me and capture so for me
this movie was the human story that I
tried to tell and not the politician
agendas who've been there one of the
fascinating things about the film is the
large amount of footage you have from
behind blockades and yeah there's
something like 30 people listed as
cinematographers as camera people you
know what it was a huge filmmakers crew
I think you know what I had
professionals and non-professionals on
the ground and each of them were trying
to capture his own story but in order to
tell it globally in order to cover all
the aspects of this movement you needed
to have it from different angles and
when all of them heard that I am doing
this movie I am planning this big
project to come in documenting
everything all of them voluntarily were
coming and bringing their footage it's
their angles their stories and they're
sharing it with me in order to deliver a
big great project together so what the
collaborations was literally
collaboration now technology definitely
helped us to do that because sometimes
you can use big camera sometimes you can
use GoPro small camera sometimes you can
use even cell phone in order to capture
the momentum because you know what
everything was so spontaneous and
unfolding so fast so you needed to
technology it basically at every second
in your hands and what I was doing there
it was the capturing of documentum we
can say documenting the history I not
trying to implement any my views I'm
trying to tell the history and at the
same time to tell the amazing
fascinating stories of my character for
example we when we will go in to see the
movie you will see a fascinating
character of 12 year old child who ran
from his home at at the beginning in the
first days of Maidan and for him it was
the his maturity you through the movie
you see he how he was growing his
maturity through this 93 days it's
technically by his own words it's a
school of his life
every consider Mike michaud's Druzhba
Mike Rogers research so you me a lot of
these fascinating characters and yes
I've been there basically to capturing
the history and trying to tell their
stories to entire world all right well
thank you very much well we'll leave it
there
we've been talking with of Jenny Avenue
ski director of the documentary winter
on fire which is about the 2014
Ukrainian uprising thank you so much
thank you for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]